In November 1979, at the Nuclear Defense Command Headquarters inside Cheyenne Mountain in Colorado, computer screens suddenly showed that Soviets had launched nuclear missiles, hundreds of them, a full-scale attack on the United States. The military response was fast and dramatic. Crews responsible for launching our missiles were put on highest alert. Fighter jets took off.
1979年11月，在科罗拉多州夏延山内的核防御指挥总部，电脑屏幕突然显示苏联发射了核导弹，成百上千枚，对美国进行了全面攻击。军队的反应迅速而剧烈。负责发射导弹的人员进入最高戒备状态。战斗机起飞了。
Before the president was asked to decide whether to retaliate, one person, a watch commander, thought something was not right and threw on the brakes. It was later discovered that a technician had accidentally put a training exercise into the computer simulating a full-scale attack. This kind of mistake, the technician who put the training exercise into the computer, is squarely in the category of human error.
在总统被要求决定是否进行报复之前，一个人，一名值班指挥官，觉得有些不对劲，踩下了刹车。后来发现，一名技术人员不小心把一个模拟全面攻击的训练演习程序输入了电脑。这种错误，那个将训练演习输入电脑的技术人员，完全属于人为错误的范畴。
And human error mistakes are especially terrifying because you never can fully do away with them. We are just prone to error. Fortunately, most of us work jobs where the mistakes we make do not result in millions of people dead or anybody dead.
人为错误尤其令人恐惧，因为你永远无法完全消除它们。我们天生就容易犯错。幸运的是，我们大多数人的工作，即使犯了错也不会导致数百万人死亡或任何人死亡。
But if you work for the US military, even when we're not at war, you can be surrounded at your job by gear whose whole purpose is to kill people. And so you can make mistakes on a scale the rest of us can't. Today on our program, we have two stories like that.
但如果你为美国军队工作，即使我们没有处于战争状态，你周围也可能全是为了杀人而设计的装备。因此，你可能犯下我们其他人无法想象的规模的错误。今天在我们的节目中，我们有两个这样的故事。
In both of these stories, the slip-ups that people make are so small. They're mistakes that, at most jobs, would mean nothing, mistakes maybe you've made yourself. One involves missiles. One involves ships.
在这两个故事中，人们所犯的失误都非常小。这些错误在大多数工作中都算不上什么，或许你自己也犯过。一个涉及导弹。一个涉及舰船。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us. And we begin with act one.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。我们先从第一幕开始。
Act One, The Wrong Tool For The Job. It's really easy for America's nuclear weapons to seem very abstract, right? We know they're out there. But it's like-- I don't know. In our minds, I think we picture like they're sitting somewhere. The power's turned off. They're parked in some missile silos, or airplane hangars, or something.
第一幕，错误的工作工具。美国的核武器似乎非常抽象，对吧？我们知道它们存在。但感觉就像——我不知道。在我们的脑海里，我想我们想象它们就停在某处。电源关着。它们停在一些导弹发射井、飞机机库或其他什么地方。
And they're there, dark until some terrible situation. And then somebody enters secret codes. And then the power goes on, and they rise from the Earth like something out of a Michael Bay movie.
它们就在那里，在某种可怕的情况发生前一直处于黑暗中。然后有人输入秘密代码。然后电源开启，它们像迈克尔·贝电影里的情节一样从地球升起。
But, of course, reality is not like that at all. In real life, the country's nuclear weapons are thousands of high-tech, very complicated machines. And the lights are not out. Things are happening.
但当然，现实完全不是那样。在现实生活中，国家的核武器是数以千计的高科技、非常复杂的机器。而且灯并没有熄灭。事情正在发生。
They need to be cleaned and taken care of and monitored by tons of people day and night, all the time. And things can go wrong. Joe Richman has this example.
它们需要日夜不停地由无数人进行清洁、维护和监控。事情可能会出错。乔·里奇曼有这个例子。
Back in September 1980, September 18, Jeff Plumb climbed into his pickup and headed toward the nuclear missile silo near a tiny town in Arkansas called Damascus. He was a 19-year-old missile technician, a new trainee, riding with another guy, David Powell, who was showing Plumb the ropes.
1980年9月18日，杰夫·普拉姆坐进他的皮卡车，前往阿肯色州大马士革一个小镇附近的核导弹发射井。他是一名19岁的导弹技术员，一名新学员，与另一名负责带他的员工大卫·鲍威尔同行。
David Powell was certified. He had done it over and over and over. For me, it was fairly new. It was the first time I was in training with David.
大卫·鲍威尔是有资质的。他一遍又一遍地做过。对我来说，这相当新奇。这是我第一次和大卫一起训练。
Plumb was a city kid from near Detroit. He remembers sitting in the truck that day watching the farms and fields fly by until eventually the truck slowed, pulled into a gravel road in the middle of nowhere, passed through some woods, and came to a fence. There wasn't much to see, a concrete slab with a handful of radio antennas sticking up out of the ground. Under that concrete slab, though, was a 146-foot silo, like an inverted 14-story building.
普拉姆是来自底特律附近的孩子。他记得那天坐在卡车里，看着农场和田野飞驰而过，直到卡车慢下来，驶入荒郊野外的一条碎石路，穿过一些树林，来到一道栅栏前。没看到什么特别的，只是一块水泥板，上面立着几根无线电天线。然而，在那块水泥板下，是一个146英尺深的发射井，就像一座倒置的14层建筑。
To get in was a sequence of gates, phones, secret codes, several super secure metal and concrete doors. And then at the bottom of the stairs, you could go two directions. Down one hall was the complex's three-story underground command center with all the communications equipment and computers and staff. A second hallway led to the missile silo.
要进去需要经过一系列大门、电话、秘密代码，以及几道超安全金属和混凝土门。然后在楼梯底部，你可以往两个方向走。一条走廊通往该设施的三层地下指挥中心，那里有所有的通信设备、电脑和工作人员。第二条走廊通往导弹发射井。
I was in awe when I would walk into the silo. When you open up the silo door, and you walk in there and look at this-- and sometimes the lighting in there was just right to where it just loomed in the dark like it was a bullet in a chamber ready to go, you know. And it had this dark black warhead on top, pure destruction at the fingertips of a couple of men.
当我走进发射井时，我感到敬畏。当你打开发射井门走进去看着它时——有时里面的灯光恰到好处，它在黑暗中隐约显现，就像膛里的子弹随时准备发射，你知道。顶部还有一个深黑色的弹头，纯粹的毁灭力量掌握在几个人手中。
The missile in the silo that day, the one Jeff Plumb was describing, was called the Titan II. At the time, the Titan II was the most powerful nuclear weapon in the American arsenal. One of them, just one, could unleash the same power as all the bombs dropped in World War II, including the atomic bombs, times three-- all the bombs in World War II times three.
发射井里的那枚导弹，就是杰夫·普拉姆描述的那枚，被称为“泰坦二号”。当时，“泰坦二号”是美国武器库中威力最大的核武器。仅一枚，就能释放出相当于二战中投下的所有炸弹威力，包括原子弹，的三倍——二战中所有炸弹威力的三倍。
But besides being America's most powerful nuclear missiles, the Titan IIs were also some of the oldest. One especially dangerous and aging part of the Titan II missile was its fuel system. By 1980, most nuclear weapons had switched to solid fuel.
但除了是美国威力最大的核导弹，“泰坦二号”也是最老旧的导弹之一。泰坦二号导弹中一个特别危险且老化的部分是其燃料系统。到1980年，大多数核武器已改用固体燃料。
But when the Titan II was developed in the 1960s, nuclear weapons used liquid fuel. Liquid fuel meant that we took a nuclear warhead, and we put it on top of two gigantic tanks and filled those tanks with incredibly volatile liquids. One tank was rocket fuel. The other was something called oxidizer. Greg Devlin also worked on the Titan II missiles.
但在1960年代开发泰坦二号时，核武器使用的是液体燃料。液体燃料意味着我们取一个核弹头，把它放在两个巨大的罐子上，并在这些罐子里装满极其不稳定的液体。一个罐子是火箭燃料。另一个是所谓氧化剂。格雷格·德夫林也曾从事泰坦二号导弹的工作。
And if they ever meet-- typically, they were meant to meet inside the motor, and then it propels it where it's going. But if they ever meet anywhere before that, you'll instantly have an explosion and a fire. So yes, it is a bomb sitting on a bomb.
如果它们相遇——通常它们注定要在发动机内部相遇，然后推动它前往目的地。但如果它们在到达那里之前在任何地方相遇，你就会立刻引发爆炸和火灾。所以是的，这是一枚坐在炸弹上的炸弹。
But even if you didn't mix these fuels, they were extremely dangerous. The oxidizer on its own was a Class A poison, the most toxic category for any chemical. It could ignite spontaneously if it touched leather, paper, cloth, wood. The fuel could ignite if it touched rust, or even if it didn't touch anything. If there were enough fumes and you waved your hand too fast, it could explode.
但即使你不混合这些燃料，它们也非常危险。氧化剂本身就是A级毒物，任何化学品中最毒的类别。如果接触到皮革、纸张、布料、木头，它可能会自燃。燃料如果接触到铁锈，甚至如果没有接触任何东西，也可能点燃。如果有足够的烟雾，你挥手太快，它都可能爆炸。
So between burns, explosions, fire, between inhalation-- if you got it on your skin, it would turn to acid. We actually had a greater fear of the fuels on board than the warhead itself.
所以，在燃烧、爆炸、火灾、吸入之间——如果你把它弄到皮肤上，它会变成酸。事实上，我们对船上燃料的恐惧比对弹头本身的恐惧还要大。
The teams that handled this hazardous stuff were called propellant transfer systems teams, or PTS teams. Surprisingly young guys-- 18, 19, 20 years old-- they were known for partying hard, speeding, driving motorcycles. Sometimes they would do this thing where they would put missile fuel in a bucket. Then they would take a ping pong ball, fill it with oxidizer, and toss it in the bucket and watch it blow up, like Mad Max beer pong.
处理这些危险物质的团队被称为推进剂输送系统团队，或PTS团队。这些令人惊讶的年轻人——18、19、20岁——以疯狂派对、超速、骑摩托车而闻名。有时他们会做那种把导弹燃料放进桶里的事。然后他们会拿一个乒乓球，装满氧化剂，扔进桶里看着它爆炸，就像《疯狂的麦克斯》版的啤酒乒乓游戏。
These were the teams that David Powell was training Jeff Plumb to be a part of. Here's Plumb.
这就是大卫·鲍威尔训练杰夫·普拉姆加入的团队。这是普拉姆。
We could do anything. That was our mindset. We were invincible, and nothing was going to stop us. You know, at 19, it just-- I didn't have any fear of things at that point in my life.
我们可以做任何事。那是我们的心态。我们是无敌的，没有什么能阻止我们。你知道，在19岁的时候，它只是——我那时生活中对任何事情都没有恐惧。
So we're in the silo. Jeff Plumb and his trainer David Powell are ready to get to work on a job that was routine maintenance. One of the missile's fuel tanks was low on pressure. So the job was just to take off something called the dust cap, kind of like a gas cap but on a nuclear missile. Then they'd have to pump in more liquid, and voila. That was it. Except before they could start--
所以我们在发射井里。杰夫·普拉姆和他的导师大卫·鲍威尔准备进行常规维护工作。导弹的一个燃料罐压力不足。所以工作只是取下所谓防尘盖，有点像油箱盖，但在核导弹上。然后他们必须泵入更多液体，瞧。就是这样。除了在他们开始之前——
They had a problem with not being able to get the hydraulic platform to come down.
他们遇到了液压平台无法下降的问题。
The hydraulic platform went up and down the side of the missile, like a platform for window washers on a highrise. And it was broken. It's worth knowing these fuel tech jobs, PTS jobs, had actually gotten to be more and more of a grind around this time because the missiles were aging.
液压平台沿着导弹侧面上下移动，就像高层建筑上的窗户清洁工平台一样。它坏了。值得一提的是，在这一时期，这些燃料技术工作，即PTS工作，实际上变得越来越繁重，因为导弹正在老化。
Materials were outdated, dilapidated, deformed. Valves leaked. Pumps failed. There was a lot of things wrong with the missile silo.
材料过时、破旧、变形。阀门泄漏。泵故障。导弹发射井里有很多问题。
So there was more work to do without more people to do it, which meant PTS guys like Powell and Plumb were increasingly overworked and burned out, hustling from one missile to another to patch them up, regularly pulling 12- and 14-hour days. And now Plumb and Powell had to wait to do this routine maintenance job in the afternoon of a long day.
所以要做的工作更多，而人手却没有增加，这意味着像鲍威尔和普拉姆这样的PTS人员越来越过度劳累和疲惫，忙着从一枚导弹赶往另一枚导弹去修补它们，经常每天工作12到14个小时。现在普拉姆和鲍威尔不得不在漫长一天的下午等待进行这项常规维护工作。
We were very anxious to get this job completed. It was a Friday night. We were young, wanting to get back to hang out with our friends and drink beer, you know. So I remember laying around up in the control center, just hanging out with these guys for hours.
我们非常渴望完成这项工作。那是周五晚上。我们很年轻，想回去和朋友聚在一起喝啤酒，你知道。所以我记得躺在控制中心，和这些人闲逛了几个小时。
Finally, they got word the hydraulic platform was up and running. So boom, green light. Plumb and Powell suited up in protective gear. Picture the guys who kidnapped E.T. And they head down the hall towards the missile silo, ready for action.
终于，他们接到通知液压平台可以使用了。所以砰，绿灯亮了。普拉姆和鲍威尔穿上防护装备。想象一下绑架E.T.的那些人。他们朝发射井走去，准备行动。
And as we were going down the long cable way, we realized we didn't have the torque wrench.
当我们沿着长长的电缆通道走的时候，我们意识到我们没有带扭矩扳手。
After hours of waiting, Plumb and Powell had left this crucial tool, the torque wrench, in their truck all the way up on the surface. It was kind of like forgetting your cell phone in your house, if your house had a bunch of enormous concrete and metal doors and required a secret code to get in. It was a pain in the ass on a long, irritating day.
等待了几个小时后，普拉姆和鲍威尔把这件关键工具，扭矩扳手，留在了地面上的卡车里。这就像把手机忘在家里一样，如果你的房子有一堆巨大的混凝土和金属门，并且需要密码才能进入的话。在漫长而令人恼火的一天里，这真是件麻烦事。
Jeff Plumb says personally he didn't know what to do. He was just learning. And the procedures, they were so meticulously laid out. You had to follow these detailed checklists. You needed the right tools.
杰夫·普拉姆说他个人不知道该怎么办。他还在学习。程序非常细致地列了出来。你必须遵循这些详细的清单。你需要正确的工具。
The checklist was the Bible, you might want to say. And Air Force regulations required us to go through that checklist and follow everything step by step.
清单是圣经，你可能会这样说。空军条例要求我们通过清单并逐步遵循每件事。
So Plumb's like, what do we do? And he looked at David Powell. And Powell said, don't worry. For what they were about to do, there was actually another tool, not the official one. But he'd used it before, so forget the torque wrench. It'll be fine.
所以普拉姆说，我们该怎么办？他看向大卫·鲍威尔。鲍威尔说，别担心。对于他们要做的事情，实际上有另一个工具，不是官方那个。但他以前用过，所以忘了扭矩扳手吧。没问题的。
So we grabbed this ratchet-- like you would pull out of your toolbox, but quite larger. If you can picture it, it was a monstrous thing because it was about three feet long. It had about a three-foot long handle. And the socket weighed anywheres from five to eight pounds. It was a big socket. So it was a large piece of steel.
所以我们抓住了这个棘轮——就像你会从工具箱里拿出来的那样，但要大得多。如果你能想象的话，它是一个怪物，因为它大约有三英尺长。它有一个大约三英尺长的手柄。插座重量在五到八磅之间。这是一个大插座。所以它是一块巨大的钢材。
Plumb looked at this wrench, like a three-foot Willy Wonka type wrench. And he wasn't so sure about it. And this giant socket wrench, besides being kind of the wrong tool, a huge, cumbersome wrong tool, it wasn't in the best shape. The two pieces of the wrench were supposed to click together, but they didn't.
普拉姆看着这个扳手，像一把三英尺长的威利·旺卡式扳手。他不太确定。这个巨大的套筒扳手，除了是错误的工具，一个笨重的错误工具外，它的状态也不太好。扳手的两部分本应卡在一起，但它们没有。
So we had a problem at that point. And so we improvised.
所以当时我们遇到了问题。于是我们随机应变。
Here's what they did. One guy held the socket over this thing they had to remove, the dust cap. The second guy held the huge handle of the ratchet and turned. Sure enough, the cap screwed right off. It worked, no problem. Great. So Plumb hands the socket off to Powell.
这是他们做的。一个人拿着套筒盖在他们必须拆除的东西——防尘盖上。第二个人拿着棘轮的巨大手柄转动。果然，盖子直接拧了下来。它奏效了，没问题。太好了。所以普拉姆把套筒递给鲍威尔。
And I remember saying to him, you've got this, right? You got-- you're OK? You got this? And he said, yeah, I got it. Let go of it. And so I remember releasing it.
我记得对他说，你拿稳了，对吧？你有——你没事吧？你拿稳了吗？他说，是的，我拿稳了。放开它。所以我记得松开了它。
And I remember seeing it kind of just fall. And it hit the platform, the socket did. And it bounced, and it went between the platform and the missile.
我记得看着它直接掉了下去。它撞到了平台，套筒撞到了。它弹了起来，掉进了平台和导弹之间。
Just to make sure you're picturing this, Plumb and Powell were working way up in the silo, like window washers on the side of a nuclear missile, on a platform. Attached to the platform was this rubber bumper that was supposed to fit right up against the missile, so there was no gap for things to fall through. But as the Titan II facilities had aged, the rubber bumper didn't fit quite right. And so there was a small gap, a socket-sized gap.
为了确保你想象到了这个画面，普拉姆和鲍威尔在发射井里很高的地方工作，就像核导弹侧面的窗户清洁工一样，在一个平台上。平台上连接着这个橡胶缓冲垫，本应紧贴导弹，这样就不会有间隙让东西掉下去。但随着泰坦二号设施的老化，橡胶缓冲垫并不太贴合。因此有一个小间隙，一个套筒大小的间隙。
It was like it bounced, and it landed perfectly in the gap, you know. It was almost like-- it was like somebody playing Tiddlywinks or something. You know how you would-- or one of those old drinking games where you bounce something and land it into the hole perfect. You know, it was just it bounced, and it was gone.
它就像弹了一下，然后完美地落入了间隙中，你知道。这几乎就像——就像有人在玩投钱游戏之类的。你知道你会怎么做——或者那些你弹东西落入完美小孔的旧喝酒游戏。你知道，它只是弹了一下，然后就消失了。
I literally watched it fall. We had dropped tools numerous times. It wasn't the first time that we ever dropped a tool and watched it fall. It was common. It just happened that when this socket fell, it went down 70 feet, 80 feet, whatever it was there, and it bounced off the thrust ring that the missile sat on, just this big giant round ring.
我简直看着它掉下去。我们多次掉落过工具。这不是我们第一次掉落工具看着它掉下去了。这是常见的。只是这次当这个套筒掉落时，它掉了70英尺、80英尺，不管是多少，它弹到了导弹所在的推力环上，就是一个巨大的圆环。
And when it fell, it picked up maximum speed and hit the top of that thrust ring and just ricocheted into the side of the missile. I heard it hit-- boom. And the next thing you know, I just seen fuel spraying out.
当它掉落时，它达到了最高速度，撞到了那个推力环的顶部，然后直接弹到了导弹侧面。我听到它撞击的声音——砰。接下来你知道的，我只看到燃料喷了出来。
I just looked at it down there. I just looked in awe. I just-- I couldn't believe what just happened. The only thing I remember saying to David was, this is not good. This is not good.
我就看着下面。我只是敬畏地看着。我只是——我不敢相信刚刚发生了什么。我记得对大卫说的唯一一件事是，这不好。这真不好。
There's a hierarchy of not good. And this kind of not good might be at the top. This kind of not good was deadly, skin-melting, highly explosive rocket fuel spraying out of a 100-foot tall intercontinental ballistic missile. On top of that missile sat the most powerful nuclear warhead in the United States of America.
坏事有等级之分。而这种不好可能是最顶级的。这种不好是致命的、会融化皮肤的、高爆炸性的火箭燃料从一枚100英尺高的洲际弹道导弹中喷射出来。在那枚导弹顶部坐着美国威力最大的核弹头。
You know, we didn't know how to respond. We looked at it for-- I don't know-- at least a minute trying to figure out what we were going to do about it. And then he contacted the team chief and told him that we had a cloud of vapor emitting from the missile.
你知道，我们不知道如何应对。我们看着它——我不知道——至少一分钟，试图弄清楚我们要对此做什么。然后他联系了团队负责人，告诉他我们有蒸汽云从导弹中排放出来。
On the other end of the radio was the missile complex's command center, a three-story underground bunker filled with monitoring equipment, control panels, and a team staffing all of it. On that team was a guy named Allan Childers. Unlike the PTS teams, Childers was an officer. And he didn't just know a few specifics or mechanics of the Titan II. Allan Childers knew the missile inside and out.
无线电的另一端是导弹综合体的指挥中心，一个三层地下掩体，装满了监控设备、控制面板和一个配备所有这些的人员团队。那个团队里有一个叫艾伦·柴尔德斯的人。与PTS团队不同，柴尔德斯是一名军官。而且他不仅知道泰坦二号的一些细节或机械原理。艾伦·柴尔德斯对这枚导弹了如指掌。
He'd spent six months studying it, reading a manual called the Dash-1 which laid out every piece of how the massive weapon worked. He and his crew spent most of their time using detailed checklists, going over all the missile systems one by one. Childers was standing behind a control panel when the call from Powell and Plumb came in.
他花了六个月时间研究它，阅读一本名为“Dash-1”的手册，详细说明了这种大规模武器如何工作的每一部分。他和他的船员大部分时间都在使用详细的清单，一个接一个地检查所有的导弹系统。当鲍威尔和普拉姆打来电话时，柴尔德斯正站在控制面板后面。
So the first thing we heard was that there was smoke in the launch duct. And of course, the commander's going, what do you mean? What's going on? And then I heard him say, what do you mean smoke in the launch-- and he was going to say duct. But I don't think he ever got the word duct out.
所以我们听到的第一件事是发射管道里有烟。当然，指挥官说，你是什么意思？发生了什么事？然后我听到他说，你是说发射管道里有烟——他本来要说“管道”这个词。但我认为他从来没有把管道这个词说出来。
As soon as that happened, the lights started coming on. And it's a klaxon alarm. And it's just waaa real loud. And all of the lights came on. So you're trained to punch the alarm off once it gets your attention, which it did, you turn the alarm off.
一旦发生这种情况，灯就开始亮了。这是警报声。声音非常大。所有的灯都亮了。所以你被训练一旦它引起你的注意就按下警报，确实如此，你关掉警报。
Well, the alarm would turn off. But it would immediately come back on again as another light came on, and another light came on. And so these indicator lights were oxidizer in the launch duct, fuel vapors in the launch duct, fire in the launch duct. Horns and klaxons were going off, sirens. Pretty much every light on the instrument panel, they were lit up.
嗯，警报会关掉。但它会立即再次响起，因为另一盏灯亮了，又一盏灯亮了。所以这些指示灯是发射管道里的氧化剂、发射管道里的燃料蒸气、发射管道里的火。号角和警报器都在响，警报声。几乎仪表板上的每一盏灯，它们都亮着。
Just moments later, Plumb and Powell had made their way from the silo back to the command center. When they got there, they found a huge scramble, everyone besides them trying to figure out what the problem was.
就在几分钟后，普拉姆和鲍威尔从发射井回到了指挥中心。当他们到达那里时，他们发现了一场巨大的混乱，除了他们以外的每个人都在试图找出问题所在。
They were trying to figure out how to deal with all these problems. They were resetting klaxons. And they didn't know what was going on. It was chaos. Because they didn't know.
他们试图弄清楚如何处理所有这些问题。他们正在重置警报。他们不知道发生了什么。这是一片混乱。因为他们不知道。
To be clear, faced with the fuel gushing out of the missile and now the command center firing questions at them, Dave Powell made a choice. It was the kind of choice you make when you're afraid of getting in trouble. He played dumb. He told them there was smoke in the silo, but nothing about the hole they had punched in the missile.
需要明确的是，面对从导弹中涌出的燃料，以及现在指挥中心向他们发出的连珠炮问询，戴夫·鲍威尔做出了选择。这是你因为害怕惹麻烦而做出的那种选择。他装傻。他告诉他们发射井里有烟，但只字未提他们在导弹上打出的洞。
Jeff Plumb made his own version of that decision, which was to keep quiet and follow Powell's lead. That created a crucial knowledge gap in the room. On the other side of that gap, Allan Childers and the rest of the command staff were left to scramble desperately, frantic to figure out what was wrong.
杰夫·普拉姆做出了他自己的那个决定版本，那就是保持沉默并跟随鲍威尔的领导。这在房间里造成了一个关键的知识缺口。在这个缺口的另一边，艾伦·柴尔德斯和指挥人员的其余部分只能绝望地乱作一团，拼命试图弄清楚出了什么问题。
All of that mattered because, if all the fuel leaked out, it's not like the missile would just sit there empty. The Titan II's fuel tanks were pressurized, like a tire. And if enough fuel leaked out, it would go flat. Or in the missile's case, it would collapse under its own weight. Enough oxidizer and fuel to carry a 330,000-pound missile across the ocean would smash together underneath a nuclear warhead.
所有这些都很重要，因为如果所有的燃料都泄漏了，导弹并不会就那样空着。泰坦二号的燃料罐是有压力的，像轮胎一样。如果泄漏了足够的燃料，它就会瘪下去。或者在导弹的情况下，它会因自身重量而坍塌。足以将一枚330,000磅的导弹运送到海洋彼岸的氧化剂和燃料会在核弹头下方撞在一起。
I just-- in my own mind, I pictured poking a hole in a pop can. And so all this pressure now is turning to a negative PSI-- which internally in my mind, I thought it's going to collapse. This tank is going to collapse in on itself.
我只是——在我的脑海里，我想象着在一个汽水罐上戳个洞。所以现在所有的压力都变成了负压——我在脑海里认为它会坍塌。这个罐子会向内坍塌。
It's sucking itself in. I was scared. I was really concerned that this thing could blow up any moment. So my concern was to get out of there. I didn't know the safety of that warhead.
它在自我吸吮。我很害怕。我真的很担心这东西随时会爆炸。所以我的担心是离开那里。我不知道那个弹头的安全性。
There were so many questions. How fast was the fuel leaking? When could the missile collapse? Could the silo contain the explosion? Could an explosion set off the nuclear warhead? Minute by minute by minute, Plumb stood silent, unsure what to do.
有太多的问题。燃料泄漏的速度有多快？导弹何时会坍塌？发射井能容纳爆炸吗？爆炸能引爆核弹头吗？一分钟又一分钟，普拉姆保持沉默，不知道该做什么。
So I just-- I kind of kept my mouth shut. You know, I didn't answer. David was the one answering the questions.
所以我只是——我有点闭上了嘴。你知道，我没有回答。大卫是那个回答问题的人。
So they never told us what had happened.
所以他们从来没有告诉我们发生了什么。
With Plumb and Powell holding out, Allan Childers and the team in the command center was slowly running out of options.
随着普拉姆和鲍威尔的隐瞒，艾伦·柴尔德斯和指挥中心的团队逐渐耗尽了选择。
We ran all of what we called our red tab checklist, our hazard checklist. And it didn't stop anything from happening. All the indicator lights stayed on. That's when the commander turned back to the team and said, what do you think it is? These indicators don't make any sense.
我们运行了所有我们称之为红色标签清单的危害清单。它并没有阻止任何事情的发生。所有的指示灯都亮着。就在那时，指挥官转头对团队说，你们觉得这是什么？这些指示灯完全没有意义。
And this was a half-hour into it. They said, we don't know. We don't know what's going on out there. All we saw was the smoke in the launch duct.
而且这已经是半个小时后了。他们说，我们不知道。我们不知道外面发生了什么。我们只看到了发射管道里的烟。
Eventually, a guy from the command center team, Rodney Holder, turned to Plumb and Powell.
最终，指挥中心团队的一名成员罗德尼·霍尔德转向了普拉姆和鲍威尔。
And Rodney asked them again, what happened? What do you guys know that we don't know? And Airman Powell started crying. And that's when the commander went-- he said, you need to tell us what is going on out there. We cannot figure it out.
罗德尼再次问他们，发生了什么？你们知道什么我们不知道的事情？飞行员鲍威尔开始哭泣。就在那时，指挥官——他说，你需要告诉我们外面到底发生了什么。我们无法弄清楚。
And that's when, as he was crying, he basically said, I dropped a socket off the end of the wrench. And it punched a hole in the side of the missile. And the commander just-- I could still picture his face. It just turned white.
就在他哭泣时，他基本上说，我从扳手末端掉落了一个套筒。它在导弹侧面打了一个洞。指挥官只是——我仍然能想象出他的脸。它变得苍白。
And he said, you need to tell the command post what you did because they're going to have questions. And I don't want to be relaying it. So he handed him the phone. He brought him over to the console. He said, I'm going to put Airman Powell on. We have a serious emergency. We just found out what's going on, and I want him to talk to you.
他说，你需要告诉指挥所你们做了什么，因为他们会有疑问。我不想复述它。所以他把电话递给他。他把他带到控制台前。他说，我要让鲍威尔飞行员接电话。我们有严重的紧急情况。我们刚发现发生了什么，我想要他跟你谈谈。
And he put him on, and he told him. I don't know how he got it out because he was crying so much, you know. I just remember everybody standing there watching, just dumbfounded.
他让他接听了，他告诉了他。我不知道他是怎么说出口的，因为他哭得太厉害了，你知道。我只记得每个人都站在那里看着，目瞪口呆。
We're talking about a socket that was bigger than your fist punching a hole in the side of a missile. You couldn't patch it if you wanted to. And by then, so much had drained out you couldn't even open up the door and lean inside without it eating up your suit.
我们谈论的是一个比你拳头还大的套筒在导弹侧面打了一个洞。如果你想修补它也补不了。到那时，大部分燃料已经流出，你甚至不能打开门探身进去，否则它会烧坏你的防护服。
So you couldn't do anything about it by then. And then the commander got back on the phone. And we were basically told to stand by. And we stood by.
所以到那时你什么也做不了了。然后指挥官又接过了电话。我们基本上被告知待命。我们就待命了。
As news of what had happened traveled up the Air Force chain of command, everyone at the missile site was instructed to wait. To wait, of course, mind you, inside a nuclear missile complex teetering on the brink of a massive explosion. Just sit tight. Quite a bit of time went by like that, couple of hours actually.
随着发生的事情的消息传到空军指挥链上，导弹基地的每个人都被指示等待。当然，请记住，是在一个处于大规模爆炸边缘的核导弹综合体内等待。就呆在那里。相当长的时间就是这样过去的，实际上有几个小时。
One of the main questions was whether to keep the missile teams underground, try to somehow, somehow fix the leak. Or is it bound to blow up, and you should get everyone out, run like hell, and hope the nuclear warhead doesn't go off? Or maybe a surprising question, is the command center actually the safest place for them?
主要问题之一是是否让导弹团队留在地下，设法以某种方式修补泄漏。还是说它注定要爆炸，你应该让每个人离开，疯狂逃跑，并希望核弹头不会爆炸？或者可能是一个令人惊讶的问题，指挥中心实际上是他们最安全的地方吗？
The launch control center, the control room, was supposed to survive a nuclear explosion.
发射控制中心，也就是控制室，本应在核爆炸中幸存下来。
Eventually, it was a colonel named John Moser back at the Air Force base in Little Rock who made the decision. He knew the command center was designed to survive a nuclear attack, like a direct hit from a Russian nuclear missile. But how could he be sure? Nothing like this had ever happened before. They were off the map.
最终，是小石城空军基地的一位名叫约翰·莫泽的上校做出了决定。他知道指挥中心被设计用来在核攻击中幸存下来，就像受到俄罗斯核导弹的直接打击一样。但他怎么能确定呢？以前从未发生过这样的事情。他们完全没经验。
For you giving the order, was it a clear call? Or was it-- were you conflicted? Were you unsure?
对于你下达命令，这是一个明确的决定吗？还是——你感到矛盾？你不确定吗？
I was not unsure. I was a straight up, clear order to evacuate because I didn't want people to be injured. We had no idea what was going to happen. We've never had an explosion or a potential explosion like this. It's never happened before. And I gave the order to evacuate.
我并不不确定。这是一个直接、明确的撤离命令，因为我不希望人们受伤。我们根本不知道会发生什么。我们从未经历过爆炸或这种潜在的爆炸。以前从未发生过。我下达了撤离命令。
And I tried to talk him out of that.
我试着劝他改变主意。
Allan Childers, back in the underground command center, disagreed with Moser's decision. He argued.
艾伦·柴尔德斯在地下指挥中心，不同意莫泽的决定。他争辩道。
I didn't think it'd blow up. And if it did blow up, I thought that the door and the complex would contain the explosion. It was underground. It had this cap on it.
我不认为它会爆炸。如果它爆炸了，我认为那道门和综合体会容纳爆炸。它在地下。它上面有盖子。
I had two blast doors protecting me that were the size of bank vault doors. And I was sitting in a facility that was designed to survive a detonation from a Russian nuclear weapon. So I thought we're safer down here than if we go up above.
我有两道防爆门保护我，它们有银行金库门那么大。我坐在一座旨在从俄罗斯核武器爆炸中幸存的设施里。所以我认为我们呆在下面比去上面更安全。
I guess I would think most people would be happy to get an order to say, get out of there.
我想大多数人都会很高兴收到命令说，离开那里。
I felt devastated. Yeah, I was devastated that I had to leave. Even to this day, it bothers me that I had to leave. Never in the history of an active missile complex had you left the missile with a warhead on it, walked away from the site with the site still running.
我感到非常沮丧。是的，我很难过我不得不离开。即使到了今天，我不得不离开也一直困扰着我。在现役导弹综合体的历史上，从来没有离开过带有弹头的导弹，在设施还在运行的情况下离开现场。
On principle, I didn't like it. The logic of it made no sense to me. I could not believe that we were leaving that complex. As in desperate shape as that site was, to leave that and not be able to tell people what was occurring out there in that launch duct-- even if we couldn't do anything, I felt like there was probably somebody was going to come up with something that we could do. And we would not be there to do it.
从原则上讲，我不喜欢它。它的逻辑对我来说毫无意义。我无法相信我们离开了那个综合体。那个地点处于如此绝望的状态，离开它却不能告诉人们发射管道里发生了什么——即使我们什么也做不了，我觉得可能有人会想出我们可以做的事情。而我们却不在那里去做。
Allan Childers made this case. He knew the Titan II missile inside and out. He knew the dangers, what could happen. He was staring at the United States on the brink of maybe setting off its most powerful nuclear missile right in the heart of the country.
艾伦·柴尔德斯提出了这个理由。他非常了解泰坦二号导弹。他知道危险，知道可能发生什么。他盯着美国，正处于可能在本国中心引爆其威力最大的核导弹的边缘。
He clung to any hope to do something, anything to claw the situation back. But Childers wasn't in charge. And eventually orders came down, and Allan Childers and everyone else in the Damascus missile complex evacuated.
他紧紧抓住任何可以做点什么、任何可以挽回局势的希望。但柴尔德斯并没有掌握指挥权。最终命令下达了，艾伦·柴尔德斯和在大马士革导弹综合体里的每个人都撤离了。
With the benefit of hindsight, we can say that from this point forward, at every point in this story when the Air Force made a decision, it arguably made the wrong decision. Here, the Air Force ordered them to abandon post. The order was to evacuate through the complex's escape hatch, which had never been used before. It was a narrow tunnel that led to a ladder, which took them several stories back up to the surface. Greg Devlin was above ground with a bunch of backup teams from the Little Rock Air Force Base.
事后看来，我们可以说，从这一点开始，在这个故事中，每当空军做出决定时，它可以说都做出了错误的决定。在这里，空军命令他们放弃岗位。命令是通过综合体的逃生舱撤离，以前从未用过。那是一个狭窄的隧道，通向一个梯子，带他们回到地面上。格雷格·德夫林和来自小石城空军基地的一群后备团队在地面上。
It was really-- it was just really eerie that night. You know, you saw smoke coming out of the vents over here. You could get whiffs of fuel, hydrazine, which has like a fish type of an odor to it. So you could smell that. So it was a very hazy, eerie-looking scenario.
那天晚上真是太诡异了。你知道，你看到烟从那边的通风口冒出来。你可以闻到燃料，联氨，它有一种鱼腥味。所以你可以闻到。这是一个非常朦胧、怪异的场景。
And then with everyone on the surface, it seems the Air Force realized what Allan Childers had been arguing all along. That the best shot at diffusing this crisis, the only way to know what was up in the silo, was to have people inside. So you guessed it. They ordered two people to go back in.
然后每个人都在地面上，空军似乎意识到艾伦·柴尔德斯一直以来所争辩的事情。化解这场危机的最好机会，了解发射井里发生了什么的方法，就是让人进入。所以你猜对了。他们命令两个人回去。
Again here, the Air Force zigged when it should have zagged. The order was not to go in the open escape hatch which everyone had just come out of. Instead, they told the folks on-site they should break in through the front doors of the missile complex.
再次在这里，空军在应该调整的时候却搞反了。命令不是进入每个人刚刚出来的那个打开的逃生舱。相反，他们告诉现场的人应该从导弹综合体的前门闯入。
With precious time ticking away, don't go through the back door, which is sitting wide open. No, break through the front door of one of the US military's most secure facilities. Or front doors is more like it-- huge, concrete, and secure metal doors-- using only these tools-- a crowbar, a hammer, a long screwdriver, a bolt cutter, and a hydraulic hand pump.
在宝贵的时间流逝中，不要走后门，它敞开着。不，闯入美国最安全的设施之一的前门。或者说前门——巨大的、混凝土的和安全的金属门——只使用这些工具——撬棍、锤子、长螺丝刀、断线钳和手动液压泵。
It's worth also mentioning had Allan Childers stayed in the command center like he wanted to, he could have opened all those doors with a push of a button. People on the site were frustrated and confused. But they followed orders and started burrowing back into the missile complex.
也值得一提的是，如果艾伦·柴尔德斯像他想要的那样留在指挥中心，他本可以用一个按钮打开所有这些门。现场的人感到沮丧和困惑。但他们服从了命令，开始挖回导弹综合体。
The first two guys to go in were myself and Rex Hukle. We suited up.
第一批进去的两个人是我和雷克斯·赫克尔。我们穿上装备。
Devlin and his partner strapped on oxygen tanks to wade through clouds of lethal rocket fuel. They broke through several doors. And then after 30 minutes, a second two-person team went in to relieve them-- and not just any team.
德夫林和他的搭档带上氧气罐，穿过致命的火箭燃料云。他们打破了几道门。30分钟后，第二支两人小组进去替换他们——不仅仅是任何团队。
One of this duo was David Livingston. Livingston was a member of the PTS team. He was also David Powell's roommate, Powell who dropped the socket that started the whole thing. Livingston was actually Powell's best friend. They made it all the way to the blast lock door where there was a meter, a meter that took readings of fuel present in the air in the silo.
这对搭档中的一个是戴维·利文斯顿。利文斯顿是PTS团队的一员。他也是戴维·鲍威尔的室友，鲍威尔就是掉落套筒引发这一切的那个人。利文斯顿实际上是鲍威尔最好的朋友。他们一直走到防爆门处，那里有一个仪表，一个测量发射井空气中燃料浓度的仪表。
And at 18,000 parts per million, it's explosion ready. It's ready to explode. That's redlined. That's pegged out. So when he called back and said, this thing's about to blow.
在百万分之18,000浓度时，它已经准备好爆炸了。它随时会爆炸。那已经触及红线了。那已经爆表了。所以当他回话说，这东西要爆炸了。
And the command center said, come back now. So him and Dave Livingston traversed back up the flights of steps. They got just above ground. And within 30 seconds, an explosion happened.
指挥中心说，马上回来。所以他和戴夫·利文斯顿穿过楼梯回到上面。他们刚到地面以上。30秒内，爆炸发生了。
It was about 3 o'clock in the morning. And I was standing up listening to a conversation. And all of a sudden, I lost communications.
大约是凌晨3点。我当时正站在那里听谈话。突然，我失去了通讯。
This is Colonel John Moser again, who was 50 miles away at the Little Rock Air Force Base calling the shots. The moment of the explosion, he was talking to people on the site, and the line went dead.
这是约翰·莫泽上校，他在50英里外的小石城空军基地指挥。爆炸发生时，他正在和现场的人交谈，线路断了。
All you've ever read is when you have a nuclear explosion, you lose communications for some time. And we lost the communications. And I just had no idea if the blast wave was going to eventually hit Little Rock Air Force Base. I had no idea.
你读到的所有内容都是当发生核爆炸时，你会失去一段时间的通讯。我们失去了通讯。我根本不知道冲击波是否最终会袭击小石城空军基地。我根本不知道。
I had no idea what was going to happen. But I thought we lost the whole works out there, everybody. And you know, I'm not a really religious guy. But I had to-- I almost dropped on my knees to say a quick prayer.
我不知道会发生什么。但我认为我们失去了外面的一切，所有人。你知道，我不是一个非常虔诚的人。但我不得不——我差点跪下来做一个简短的祈祷。
While John Moser was at the Little Rock Air Force Base waiting for everything around him to be swept off the Earth by a nuclear explosion, Allan Childers was back at the Damascus missile site.
当约翰·莫泽在小石城空军基地等待他周围的一切被核爆炸从地球上抹去时，艾伦·柴尔德斯回到了大马士革导弹基地。
It's so hard to describe an explosion like that. The only thing you see is this huge-- I mean nighttime turned into day. It was unbelievable. Because it was so bright all of a sudden.
描述那样的爆炸太难了。你唯一看到的是这个巨大的——我的意思是夜晚变成了白天。这令人难以置信。因为它突然变得太亮了。
And I literally turned to one of the guys. And I was feeling my chest. And I said, it couldn't be a nuclear explosion because we're still here. And that's what dawned on me. We were still there.
我真的转向其中一个人。我摸着自己的胸口。我说，这不可能是核爆炸，因为我们还在这里。这就是我意识到的。我们还在那里。
Man. Oh my gosh. I was standing at the fence. And I was facing the silo when it exploded.
天哪。我的天哪。我当时正站在栅栏旁。爆炸时我正对着发射井。
Again, Greg Devlin, one of the guys on the first team to go back in and who was watching as the second team worked.
再次是格雷格·德夫林，第一批返回的队员之一，当时正看着第二支队伍工作。
It was just a bang, the loud sound, and the concussion of wind. It was just-- it was like bang. It was like being in front of a-- picture yourself as nothing's there, but you just got hit by a Mack truck.
那只是一声巨响，巨大的声音，还有风的冲击。它就像——砰。这就像站在——想象你自己身前什么都没有，但你刚刚被一辆麦克卡车撞了。
And all of a sudden, rocks started falling. It was like rain falling. And it was all this gravel from the complex. And metal started falling out of the sky. And everybody started to run.
突然，石头开始落下。就像下雨一样。那是综合体的所有砾石。金属开始从天上掉下来。每个人都开始跑。
The chunks of concrete that were landing everywhere were as-- I mean everywhere-- were as big as coffee tables. The real big ones were as big as pickup trucks and school buses and stuff like that. Those were everywhere. You could hear them hitting the ground around me. Man, it was like boom, boom, boom.
到处落下的混凝土块——我的意思是到处都是——有咖啡桌那么大。真正大的有皮卡车和校车那么大。它们到处都是。你可以听到它们在我周围撞击地面的声音。天哪，就像砰、砰、砰。
I got up immediately. I took off running. I got five steps away, and a chunk of concrete hit the ground behind me as big as a-- bigger than a school bus. The trees were on fire. The grass was on fire. The only light we had was fires. And you could see the shadows of just about everything because there was so much fire around there. It was like being in this forest fire without a forest being around you.
我立即起身。我跑开了。我跑了五步，一块混凝土落在我身后，比校车还大。树木着火了。草地着火了。我们唯一的照明就是火。你可以看到几乎所有东西的影子，因为周围有太多的火。就像身处森林大火中，周围却没有森林。
And then for just a second or two, it was this one point in time where there was no sound at all. It was like a total calm peace, kind of like the end of the world, for 10 seconds. And then you heard all the screaming and crying and guys yelling, oh my god, I'm hurt.
然后有一两秒钟，那是那一刻，一点声音都没有。就像完全平静祥和，有点像世界末日，持续了10秒钟。然后你听到了所有的尖叫声和哭声，人们在喊，我的天，我受伤了。
This is the CBS Evening News with Walter Cronkite.
这是哥伦比亚广播公司晚间新闻，我是沃尔特·克朗凯特。
Good evening. Modern age terror swept an area of rural Arkansas today when fuel exploded around a nuclear warhead in a missile silo. The incident began when officials say a workman dropped a wrench.
晚上好。现代恐怖今天席卷了阿肯色州农村地区，当时燃料在导弹发射井的核弹头周围爆炸。据官员称，事件开始于一名工人掉落了一个扳手。
The morning after, everyone was trying to sort out what had happened-- the press, Air Force, local law enforcement, the public. Simply put, the fuel exploded. The nuke didn't go off. The Air Force was keeping tight-lipped, refusing to confirm whether there had even been a nuclear warhead on site.
第二天早上，每个人都在试图整理发生了什么——媒体、空军、当地执法部门、公众。简单地说，燃料爆炸了。核弹没响。空军保持缄默，拒绝确认现场是否确实有核弹头。
For the survivors, the injuries were extensive. Greg Devlin had burns on his face, neck, and back. His skin was burned off his left hand. Others had extensive burns and broken bones. One airman, David Livingston, was dead. Remember Livingston was David Powell's roommate and best friend.
对于幸存者来说，伤势很严重。格雷格·德夫林的脸、脖子和背部被烧伤。他左手的皮肤被烧没了。其他人有大面积烧伤和骨折。一名空军士兵戴维·利文斯顿死了。记得利文斯顿是戴维·鲍威尔的室友和最好的朋友。
Livingston was on the second team to go back in. And he was standing just outside the silo when it blew. All that meant Powell had kind of dropped the socket into some huge Rube Goldberg machine of bad luck and indirectly killed his best friend.
利文斯顿是第二支返回的队伍中的成员。当它爆炸时，他正站在发射井外。这意味着鲍威尔把套筒掉进了一个巨大的坏运气机器中，并间接杀死了他最好的朋友。
At the missile site, the damage was staggering, a monument to just how dangerous the situation had been. The missile silo's door, a 1.5 million-pound slab of concrete and steel, had blown off, spun like a Frisbee, and landed more than 500 feet away. And then there was the biggest question. Where was the nuclear warhead?
在导弹基地，破坏是惊人的，是情况有多危险的一座丰碑。导弹发射井的门，一块150万磅的混凝土和钢板，被炸飞，像飞盘一样旋转，落在了500多英尺外。还有一个最大的问题。核弹头在哪里？
The warhead ended up about a quarter mile away, intact, in a ditch. To me, that's amazing.
弹头最终在四分之一英里外，完好无损，在一个沟里。对我来说，那太神奇了。
As for the question of whether the nuclear warhead could have gone off, the military would later say no, impossible. There were too many safety measures in place. But lots of people who were familiar with nuclear weapons, who know them well, who worked on the Titan II, they say it absolutely could have. If the warhead had gone off, it's estimated the fallout could have reached more than 400 miles and killed people in Arkansas, Missouri, Kentucky, Illinois, and Indiana.
至于核弹头是否会爆炸的问题，军方后来会说不，不可能。有太多的安全措施。但是许多熟悉核武器的人，了解它们的人，在泰坦二号上工作的人，他们说绝对可能。如果弹头爆炸了，据估计放射性尘埃可能蔓延超过400英里，并杀害阿肯色州、密苏里州、肯塔基州、伊利诺伊州和印第安纳州的人民。
After Damascus, the Air Force officially blamed the incident on human error-- so Jeff Plumb and David Powell, who dropped the socket. That never sat well with many of the people who were there who worked at Damascus, including Jeff Plumb.
在大马士革之后，空军正式将事故归咎于人为错误——也就是杰夫·普拉姆和大卫·鲍威尔，他们掉落了套筒。这让在大马士革工作的许多人感到不安，包括杰夫·普拉姆。
It wasn't uncommon for that to happen. Every guy that worked in those silos I know dropped a wrench or a tool at some point in his career-- every guy. And if they tell you they didn't, they're lying. Because there was no way to get around that. It just happened that one went the wrong way.
这种情况并不罕见。我知道在那些发射井工作的每个人在职业生涯中的某个时候都掉落过扳手或工具——每个人。如果他们告诉你他们没有，他们就在撒谎。因为没法避免。只是碰巧那个掉向了错误的方向。
Plumb says the Air Force knew that. They knew then, and they know now. That even when the stakes are nuclear weapons, human error is a factor. After Damascus, workers were required to tie tools to their bodies. One solution to the problem of human error, the lanyard.
普拉姆说空军知道这一点。他们那时知道，现在也知道。即使风险是核武器，人为错误也是一个因素。大马士革之后，工人被要求将工具绑在身上。解决人为错误问题的一个办法，挂绳。
We should say we asked David Powell to talk about all this, but he didn't want to talk about it. We did learn that he only recently told his wife and family. He'd kept it secret for years and years. Jeff Plumb says he thinks Powell really struggled with it, just like he did too.
我们应该说我们请大卫·鲍威尔谈谈这一切，但他不想谈。我们确实了解到他直到最近才告诉他的妻子和家人。他保守秘密多年又多年。杰夫·普拉姆说他认为鲍威尔真的很挣扎，就像他自己一样。
After the incident, Jeff Plumb had an episode where he snapped, lost it, and started throwing beer bottles against the wall in a room at the Air Force base. It was bad. The Air Force demoted him, and things went downhill from there. He was eventually discharged from the Air Force. Even now years later, he finds the accident hard to talk about.
事件发生后，杰夫·普拉姆经历了一次崩溃，失去了理智，开始在空军基地的一个房间里朝墙上扔啤酒瓶。这很严重。空军将他降职，情况从那时起一落千丈。他最终被空军开除了。即使是多年后的现在，他仍然觉得那次事故难以启齿。
I'll tell the story. And I'll begin to tell the story to someone, and then you just get caught up in it. You tell that story over-- I've told it I don't know how many times, you know, and relived it a few times. And I think I really have-- I think I've had enough, you know.
我会讲这个故事。我会开始跟某人讲这个故事，然后你就会陷进去。你一遍又一遍地讲那个故事——我不知道讲了多少次，你知道，又重温了几次。我想我真的——我想我已经受够了，你知道。
Yeah, just thinking back on it, it just wasn't a very good time in my life at that point. So I think I really don't want to tell the story anymore. So yeah, this will be the last time. Yeah. This will be the last time.
是的，回想起来，那只是我生命中不太好的一段时间。所以我认为我真的不想再讲这个故事了。所以是的，这将是最后一次。是的。这将是最后一次。
One of the remarkable things about Damascus is actually how unremarkable it was, how many accidents there have been like this one. When it comes to nuclear weapons, it's so easy to assume that everything is all taken care of, oversight is airtight, precautions and protocols are in place. The stakes are so serious.
大马士革事件最引人注目的事情实际上是它有多么不引人注目，发生了多少次这样的事故。说到核武器，太容易假设一切都处理得很好，监管是天衣无缝的，预防措施和协议都已到位。风险是如此严重。
But the 70-year history of our nuclear weapons is littered with accidents like what happened in Arkansas. An accident like Damascus could never happen again because our missiles no longer use liquid fuels. So that risk is gone.
但我们核武器70年的历史充斥着像阿肯色州那样发生的事故。像大马士革这样的事故再也不会发生了，因为我们的导弹不再使用液体燃料。所以那种风险消失了。
But there are other risks. There are new ones-- enemies hacking into missile systems over the internet, low morale and other personnel issues among the people who maintain and operate our nuclear arsenal, and aging facilities and technology. I talked to half a dozen experts who are familiar with our nuclear weapons, from places like Yale, Berkeley, Harvard, and former military officials.
但还有其他风险。有新的风险——敌人通过互联网入侵导弹系统，维护和操作我们核武库的人员士气低落和其他人事问题，以及老化的设施和技术。我采访了半打熟悉我们核武器的专家，来自耶鲁、伯克利、哈佛等地方，以及前军事官员。
They worry about mishaps and accidents that most of us never consider with weapons most of us never think about. All of them pointed out the accident at Damascus, no one saw that coming. There were supposed to be safeguards to prevent that from ever happening. One military expert said, the kind of accident we should worry about is the kind that seems impossible, like what happened in Damascus. Again, Greg Devlin.
他们担心我们大多数人从未考虑过的失误和事故，涉及我们大多数人从未想过的武器。所有人都指出了大马士革的事故，没有人预见到这一点。本应有保障措施来防止这种情况发生。一位军事专家说，我们应该担心的事故是看起来不可能的那种，就像大马士革发生的那样。再次是格雷格·德夫林。
One dropped socket that A, should have let's just say not dropped; but B, should have never got past a platform; C, shouldn't have hit the thrust mount; D, shouldn't have hit the missile. If it hit, it shouldn't have punctured a hole in it. I mean there are so many things that shouldn't have happened, but one dropped socket wiped out an entire nuclear missile system. One dropped socket, nine-pound socket, took it all out. There's no one that thought that scenario out.
一个掉落的套筒，A，应该假设不掉落；但B，永远不应该掉过平台；C，不应该撞到推力架；D，不应该撞到导弹。如果撞到了，不应该打穿一个洞。我的意思是，有太多的事情不应该发生，但一个掉落的套筒抹杀了一个完整的核导弹系统。一个掉落的套筒，九磅重的套筒，把它全部毁了。没有人想过那种方案。
A single dropped tool setting off the explosion of a nuclear missile. Greg Devlin says he would have put the chance of that at zero.
单个掉落的工具引发核导弹爆炸。格雷格·德夫林说他会把那次事故的可能性定为零。
Joe Richman is the founder of Radio Diaries. To make their podcast your next new podcast, you can find it at radiodiaries.org or wherever you get your podcasts. Eric Molinsky helped report this story.
乔·里奇曼是Radio Diaries的创始人。要让他们的播客成为你的下一个新播客，你可以在radiodiaries.org或你获取播客的任何地方找到它。埃里克·莫林斯基帮助报道了这个故事。
A special thanks to Eric Schlosser, who was a huge help to us and whose book on nuclear arms safety Command and Control covers this and other accidents like it. Eric pointed out to us that while the United States no longer uses liquid-fueled nuclear weapons, they are still in use in North Korea.
特别感谢埃里克·施洛瑟，他给了我们极大的帮助，他关于核武器安全《指挥与控制》的书涵盖了这一事故和类似的事故。埃里克向我们指出，虽然美国不再使用液体燃料核武器，但它们仍在朝鲜使用。
Coming up, from mistakes in the past to mistakes in the present. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，从过去的错误到现在的错误。芝加哥公共广播电台将在节目继续时在一分钟内播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Human Error in Volatile Situations. We've arrived at act two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并带给你关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，《动荡局势下的人为错误》。我们已经来到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Erring Like a Sailor. In August, a Navy destroyer, the USS John McCain, collided with an oil tanker. 10 sailors died. This is just two months after another destroyer, the USS Fitzgerald, crashed into a container ship, killing seven sailors.
第二幕，像水手一样犯错。8月，一艘海军驱逐舰，美国约翰·麦凯恩号，与一艘油轮相撞。10名水手死亡。这就在另一艘驱逐舰，美国菲茨杰拉德号，撞上一艘集装箱船并导致7名水手死亡的两个月后。
After the McCain crash, rumors swirled around that somebody, Russia or China or North Korea, hacked into the ship's navigation systems, caused the crashes. People said maybe hackers projected a fake GPS signal, so the ships didn't really know where they were. Maybe the hacking rumors got so much traction because it just felt better to believe the collisions were caused by an enemy, rather than the truth.
麦凯恩号相撞后，有传言称有人，俄罗斯、中国或朝鲜，黑进了船的导航系统，导致了碰撞。人们说可能黑客投射了假的GPS信号，所以船根本不知道它们在哪里。也许黑客传言如此盛行，因为相信碰撞是由敌人造成的，而不是真相，感觉更好。
After an investigation, it became clear we crashed the ships ourselves. It was human error. Months ago, one of our producers, Stephanie Foo, started looking into these accidents and learned something about the Navy, an underlying reality about daily life for sailors the Navy has said played a role in these accidents. And it honestly really surprised us. Here's Stephanie.
调查后，很明显是我们自己撞了船。这是人为错误。几个月前，我们的一位制作人斯蒂芬妮·傅开始调查这些事故，并了解了一些关于海军的事情，一种海军已表示在这些事故中发挥作用的关于水手日常生活的潜在现实。说实话，这真的让我们感到惊讶。这是斯蒂芬妮。
Ty is a sailor who served on a destroyer in the Pacific for four years, the USS John McCain. He moved to another Navy job in 2016. He was friends with four of the 10 men who died on the McCain and really close to one guy in particular, Jacob Drake. Because Ty's still in the Navy, he asked that we use a different name for him. And we had an actor, Scott Shepherd, replace his voice.
泰是一个在太平洋的一艘驱逐舰，美国约翰·麦凯恩号，服役了四年的水手。他在2016年调到了另一个海军岗位。他是麦凯恩号上死亡的10个人中4人的朋友，与其中一个人，雅各布·德雷克，特别亲近。因为泰仍然在海军服役，他要求我们使用不同的名字。我们请了一位演员，斯科特·谢泼德，替换他的声音。
He was basically like a little chihuahua. This guy was probably 5'4" or 5'5". And then whenever we'd be roughhousing, and he'd punch me in the shoulder. And then I'd grab him around his shoulders, pick him up, and then put my other arm underneath his knees and just sandwich him up in the air. So that was how we got to be really, really good friends.
他基本上就像一只小吉娃娃。这家伙大概5英尺4英寸或5英尺5英寸。每当我们在打闹时，他就会打我的肩膀。然后我就抓住他的肩膀，把他抱起来，把我的另一只手臂放在他的膝盖下面，直接在空中把他三明治夹起来。所以这就是我们成为非常好朋友的方式。
Jacob Drake was 21 when he died. At first, Ty wondered if the hacking rumors were true. But a few months ago, at one of the sailor's funerals, a group of guys who were on the McCain during the collision started talking.
雅各布·德雷克去世时21岁。起初，泰怀疑黑客传言是否属实。但几个月前，在其中一名水手的葬礼上，一群在碰撞发生时在麦凯恩号上的家伙开始交谈。
And Ty learned what happened up on the bridge that morning at 5:24 AM. The sailors who were supposed to steer the ship didn't really know how to steer this particular destroyer and made a series of mistakes that caused the ship to drift portside right as it was approaching one of the most crowded waterways in the world, the Strait of Malacca. It turned left into the the nose of an oil tanker.
泰了解了那天早上5:24在舰桥上发生的事情。本应驾驶那艘船的水手们并不真正知道如何驾驶这艘特定的驱逐舰，并犯了一系列错误，导致船只在接近世界上最拥挤的水道之一马六甲海峡时向左漂移。它向左转进了油轮的船头。
The tanker punctured a hole in the USS McCain's hull, which flooded the berthing and drowned his sleeping friends. When Ty found out the reason for the crash--
油轮在麦凯恩号的船体上打了一个洞，淹没了泊位，淹死了他睡梦中的朋友们。当泰发现碰撞的原因时——
I was [BLEEP] pissed. Operator error is what cost me four really good friends and 10 brothers total. It's a total waste. Like I don't know how else to describe that. We're taught from boot camp on attention to detail. That's what gets me the most because literally how small it was.
我[脏话]气疯了。操作错误是我失去四个真正好朋友和总共10个兄弟的原因。这简直是浪费。我不知道怎么描述。我们从新兵训练营就被教导注意细节。这就是让我最难受的地方，因为那错误实在是太小了。
The USS McCain was just one of six major accidents within the Navy's 7th Fleet this year. The Fitzgerald is also in the 7th Fleet. The most recent incident was the day before Thanksgiving when a Navy plane trying to land on an aircraft carrier crashed in the Pacific Ocean. Three men were killed.
美国麦凯恩号只是今年海军第七舰队发生的六起重大事故之一。菲茨杰拉德号也在第七舰队。最近的一次事件发生在感恩节的前一天，当时一架试图在航空母舰上着陆的海军飞机在太平洋坠毁。三名男子丧生。
Most years, there are just a handful of deaths on Navy ships, three or fewer. This year, there were 17. About a month after Ty went to that funeral, the Navy released a report that detailed the causes of both the Fitzgerald and McCain collisions. The report verified the story Ty had heard.
大多数年份，海军舰艇上的死亡人数只有寥寥数人，三个或更少。今年，有17人。在泰参加葬礼大约一个月后，海军发布了一份详细说明菲茨杰拉德号和麦凯恩号碰撞原因的报告。报告证实了泰听到的故事。
It also described the panic of the sailors and how they struggled to save each other, pulling each other up ladders, using the Jaws of Life to extract trapped sailors from their crushed racks. The report includes scratchy, hand-drawn pictures of what the sailors saw as they tried to exit their racks, how the water was up to their necks. It describes how afterward, when divers went into the berthings to retrieve the bodies, one body was found underneath a television and another inside a bathroom.
它还描述了水手们的恐慌以及他们如何努力互相拯救，互相拉上梯子，使用切割器将受困的水手从他们被挤压的架子中救出。报告包括水手们试图离开架子时所看到的草图，水如何淹到他们的脖子。它描述了后来，当潜水员进入泊位打捞尸体时，一具尸体被发现在电视机下面，另一具在浴室里。
The report also concluded that a long list of errors led up to each crash. The crew wasn't properly trained. They used their radars incorrectly. Then there were the sailors who were on watch. On the Fitzgerald, they looked out only one side of the ship, while ignoring the other.
报告还得出结论，一长串错误导致了每起碰撞。船员没有接受适当的训练。他们错误地使用了雷达。然后是那些值班的水手。在菲茨杰拉德号上，他们只看船的一侧，而忽略了另一侧。
All these mistakes left some people wondering, why were the crews so unbelievably sloppy? Rick Hoffman is a retired Navy captain and an expert on Navy collisions. He spent five years of his career analyzing case studies of crashes to teach young officers about them.
所有这些错误让一些人纳闷，为什么船员如此难以置信地草率？瑞克·霍夫曼是一名退休的海军上校，也是海军碰撞方面的专家。他在职业生涯中花了五年时间分析碰撞案例研究，教导年轻军官有关它们的知识。
He pointed out in both the McCain and the Fitzgerald crashes, no one set off the collision alarm to warn the rest of the crew. No one shouted, hey, there's a 700-foot ship heading our way. It shocked him.
他指出在麦凯恩号和菲茨杰拉德号的碰撞中，没有人触发碰撞警报来警告其余的船员。没有人喊，嘿，有一艘700英尺的船朝我们冲过来。这让他感到震惊。
There was no indication that the bridge was even aware that they were about to have a collision. They didn't sound the collision alarm. They didn't notify the crew. They didn't tell the captain. And that's mind-boggling. That's mind-boggling.
没有任何迹象表明舰桥甚至意识到他们即将发生碰撞。他们没有拉响碰撞警报。他们没有通知船员。他们没有告诉船长。这令人匪夷所思。这令人匪夷所思。
These people are looking out the window. So you've got a sailor back there on a headset communicating with the bridge what he sees. And why that kid wasn't screaming is a mystery to me.
这些人正在看着窗外。所以你有一个水手在耳机上和舰桥沟通他所看到的。为什么那个孩子没有尖叫对我来说是一个谜。
I found some people who felt like they knew the answer to that mystery. Months before the Navy report on the crashes came out, I was on Reddit, where there's a community of people in the Navy. And I came across a long, impassioned discussion about the cause of the crashes.
我发现了一些觉得他们知道那个谜题答案的人。在海军关于碰撞的报告发布前几个月，我在Reddit上，那里有一个海军人员社区。我偶然发现了一场关于碰撞原因的漫长、热烈的讨论。
It began with a single comment, quote, "I wonder if the watch were sleep deprived." And then posters just responded in droves-- about 1,000 posts of sailors and vets telling story after story about how little sleep they'd gotten during their time in the Navy. Many people talked about averaging three to four hours of sleep per night, every night.
它以一个评论开始，引用，“我怀疑值班人员是否睡眠不足。”然后海报蜂拥而至——大约1,000名水手和老兵发布了故事，讲述他们在海军期间睡得有多么少。许多人谈到平均每晚只睡三到四个小时，每天如此。
And that years afterward, long after they'd left the military, they still had trouble sleeping more than four hours a night, which sometimes led to issues with depression. Someone remembered being so tired that they reported the moon as an enemy contact. One guy talked about cracking his head against a panel as he passed out from exhaustion onto it.
并且在多年之后，在他们离开军队很久之后，他们仍然很难每晚睡超过四个小时，这有时会导致抑郁问题。有人记得因为太累而把月亮报告为敌人接触。一个人谈到因为精疲力竭而晕倒在面板上，撞破了头。
The commenters believed that these recent accidents weren't just caused by human error. It was human error as a result of sleep deprivation. It seemed crazy that giant, billion dollar ships could crash, that people could die because of something as simple as sleep.
评论者认为，这些最近的事故不仅仅是由人为错误引起的。这是睡眠不足导致的人为错误。似乎疯狂的是，价值数十亿美元的巨型舰船会相撞，人们会因为像睡眠这样简单的事情而死亡。
So I started calling people in the Navy or who are connected to the Navy, talking to them about this. And over four months of reporting, the picture I got was staggering. Sleep deprivation seemed widespread. And there was this phrase people kept saying that sums up the Navy's attitude toward sleep.
所以我开始给海军或与海军有关的人打电话，和他们谈论这件事。在四个月的报道中，我看到的画面令人震惊。睡眠不足似乎很普遍。人们一直说一句话，总结了海军对睡眠的态度。
You sleep when you're dead.
你死后自会安息。
It's like a sleep when you're dead stigma.
这就像一种“死后再睡”的耻辱感。
You're going to sleep when you're dead.
你死后自会去睡。
Here's a bunch of Navy personnel.
这是一群海军人员。
You criticize somebody by telling them they're a rack hound, which means they sleep all the time.
你通过告诉别人他们是床虫来批评某人，这意味着他们一直都在睡觉。
You know, what are you? Some kind of a weeny? You only been up for two days? Come on. What's wrong with you?
你知道，你是什么？某种娘娘腔吗？你只醒了两天？拜托。你怎么了？
Suck it up. You going to [BLEEP] cry about it? Yeah. Wake up. Drink another cup of coffee.
忍着吧。你打算[脏话]哭吗？是的。醒醒。再喝一杯咖啡。
So yeah, I mean that's the attitude.
所以是的，我的意思是这就是那种态度。
In November, when the Navy released its public report about the McCain and Fitzgerald accidents, it confirmed that fatigue was one of the causes. Mike Love is one of the sailors who posted on the Reddit thread. And as soon as he heard about the Fitzgerald crash, he thought--
11月，当海军发布关于麦凯恩号和菲茨杰拉德号事故的公开报告时，它证实了疲劳是原因之一。迈克·洛夫是在Reddit帖子上发表评论的水手之一。当他听到菲茨杰拉德号碰撞的消息时，他想——
It wasn't even-- to me, it was like, well, obviously that's what had happened. It's that you're having a kid that's-- I don't know-- 19, 20 years old that you've been working 20 hours a day-- you're going to stand him out in the dark and tell him to look for stuff. Like what do you think is going to happen? He's going to [BLEEP] fall asleep.
它甚至没有——对我来说，就像，嗯，显然发生了那种事。那就是你有一个——我不知道——19、20岁左右的孩子，你已经让他每天工作20个小时——你要让他站在黑暗中，告诉他寻找东西。就像你认为会发生什么？他会[脏话]睡着。
Mike served from 2004 to 2008. This is a rare thing, but he explained that he would sometimes work 24-hour days-- so work a whole entire 24 hours, and then go straight on to the next 24 hours. And he told me a story that really sticks out in his memory. He was stationed aboard a dock landing ship which-- well, all you need to know is that it's a bigass ship.
迈克从2004年服役到2008年。这是一件稀罕事，但他解释说他有时会进行24小时工作日——所以整整工作24小时，然后直接进入下一个24小时。他告诉我一个在他的记忆中非常深刻的故事。他被派往一艘船坞登陆舰，嗯，你只需要知道它是一艘巨型大船。
And it was in the waters around Kuwait about 10 years ago. One night, he was doing rounds in a smaller boat, a patrol boat with five people in it. And they were circling the bigass ship. The guy who was driving the patrol boat looked tired. So Mike offered to take over.
它大约10年前在科威特附近的水域。一天晚上，他正在一艘较小的船上巡逻，一艘载有五个人的巡逻艇。他们正在绕着那艘大船转。驾驶巡逻艇的人看起来很累。所以迈克提出接手。
And I was like, man, you're looking pretty tired, you know. Do you mind if I step in? He was like, thank you. I appreciate it. It's been a long day. I was like, yeah, I feel you.
我说，哥们，你看上去很累，你知道。你不介意我接手吗？他说，谢谢。我很感激。这是漫长的一天。我说，是的，我理解你。
And as I was thinking about this, I was just kind of remembering, I wonder how long I had been awake. And I remember questioning this. Yeah, that was-- I mean yeah, that would've been going on 72 hours right there.
当我想到这一点时，我只是在回忆，我想知道我醒了多久。我记得问过这个问题。是的，那是在那持续了72小时。
Jesus. 72 hours.
天哪。72小时。
Yeah. And I put my headphones in. And I'll never forget. It was playing Killswitch Engage. And I was trying to keep myself up, you know, some heavy metal-- ba, ba, ba.
是的。我戴上耳机。我永远不会忘记。它当时在放Killswitch Engage。我试图让自己保持清醒，你知道，一些重金属——哒，哒，哒。
I remember the officer saying something into my ear. And he was like, yeah, you know, you don't need to swing it so close for the patrols. We can take a little time. And I look up. I was like, OK, OK.
我记得军官在我的耳朵里说了些什么。他说，是的，你知道，你不必在巡逻时转得那么近。我们可以花点时间。我抬头看。我说，好的，好的。
So he was driving around the bigger ship. And all of a sudden--
所以他正在绕着那艘大船开。突然——
And then I just remember hearing the engines kind of vvrrvv. And I just hear like, Love, Love, Love. And I was like, what? And I looked up. And holy cow. You know, swung full right. I was maybe-- maybe 60 meters from the side of the ship.
然后我只记得听到引擎发出vvrrvv的声音。我只听到，洛夫，洛夫，洛夫。我说，什么？我抬头看。天哪。你知道，全速向右转。我当时可能——可能离船边只有60米。
Heading full speed towards it. He swerved away with just seconds to spare.
全速冲向它。他只差几秒钟就避开了。
It was very, very close. You know, that would have easily, easily, easily killed us all.
这非常、非常危险。你知道，那本来很容易、很容易、很容易就把我们全部杀死了。
His shipmates started freaking out. And even then, Mike still couldn't keep his eyes open.
他的船友开始抓狂。即使在那时，迈克仍然无法睁开眼睛。
And I remember him saying like, are you kidding me? You're falling asleep as I'm talking? And as he's yelling at me. And I was like, holy crap. He's yelling in my ear, and I still am that tired that I had fallen asleep.
我记得他说像，你在开玩笑吗？我在跟你说话你都睡着了？他在我耳边大喊。我仍然那么累，以至于我睡着了。
This story was like a lot of stories on the Reddit thread-- fatigue-induced close calls. And as Mike was telling me about this, he started describing what it felt like to be so sleep deprived. And just the way he talked about it, I realized, oh, you know this feeling really well. Like he'd been down that road so many times he'd come to recognize landmarks on the way.
这个故事就像Reddit线上的许多故事一样——疲劳引起的千钧一发。当迈克告诉我这件事时，他开始描述那种如此睡眠不足的感觉。就他谈论它的方式，我意识到，哦，你知道这种感觉非常清楚。就像他走那条路走了很多次，以至于他认出了路上的标志。
When you hit a 24-hour mark or so, you're going to get your general tired. You hit that wall where you're like, oh man, I can barely keep my eyes open. And then once you come out of that, you start to suffer loss of motor skills, your finer motor skills, your ability to focus your eyes.
当你达到24小时左右时，你会感到一般性疲劳。你撞到那堵墙，你会觉得，哦，天哪，我几乎睁不开眼。然后一旦你走出那堵墙，你就开始遭受运动技能的丧失，你的精细运动技能，你集中眼睛的能力。
And then, for me anyway, it starts with the auditory hallucinations. And then you'll get the visual hallucinations that will start at the corner of your eyes. Right in the shadows where your eyes kind of can't focus, your brain will be interpreting them as movement.
然后，对我来说，它从听觉幻觉开始。然后你会得到在眼角开始的视觉幻觉。就在你的眼睛有点无法聚焦的阴影中，你的大脑会把它们解释为运动。
So as you hit day two or day three, you start to lose the ability to determine between wakefulness and sleep. So you can be talking to someone and actually fall asleep with your eyes wide open. And then the conversation will turn to complete gibberish. Like what are you talking about, dude? What did you just say? What do you mean? I said this.
所以当你进入第二天或第三天，你开始丧失区分清醒和睡眠的能力。所以你可以在和某人谈话时实际上睁大眼睛睡着。然后对话会变成完全胡言乱语。就像你在说什么，老兄？你刚才说了什么？什么意思？我说这个。
Scientists have studied this. National Institutes of Health studies have given cognition tests to sleepy and drunk people. And they showed that being awake for 23 hours is equivalent to being well over the limit for driving drunk.
科学家研究过这个问题。美国国立卫生研究院的研究对昏昏欲睡和醉酒的人进行了认知测试。结果显示，保持清醒23小时相当于严重超过了酒驾限制。
Reaction times for people awake that long were 200% worse than people who are well-rested. Their hand-eye coordination was 30% worse. On some tests, they made twice as many mistakes.
保持清醒那么长时间的人的反应时间比休息充分的人差200%。他们的手眼协调能力差30%。在某些测试中，他们犯的错误是平时的两倍。
You've got a whole ship of people driving drunk, and that's unacceptable.
你有一整船人酒驾，这不可接受。
David Larter is a Navy vet, now a journalist for Defense News. And he's been thinking about the sleep issue and reporting on it for years. A few months ago, Larter was on an NPR program, 1A, with a retired admiral, Terry McKnight, who took a very old school Navy tack on all this. He said basically sailors have to deliver no matter what. You're an adult. You figure out when to sleep.
戴维·拉特是一位海军老兵，现在是《防务新闻》的记者。他多年来一直思考睡眠问题并对此进行报道。几个月前，拉特在NPR的一个节目1A上，与一位退休的海军上将特里·麦克奈特一起，他采取了一种非常老派的海军作风。他说基本水手必须交付，无论发生什么。你是个成年人。你自己决定什么时候睡觉。
The Navy is not Carnival Cruise Lines. This is hard work. People know that their watch-- they know when they're going to stand watch. And they should take the opportunity to be well-rested before they get up there.
海军不是嘉年华邮轮公司。这是艰苦的工作。人们知道他们的值班——他们知道什么时候值班。他们应该抓住机会在上去之前休息好。
Larter told me that the Admiral's comment made him furious. He brought it up twice in our interview, fuming each time.
拉特告诉我，这位上将的评论让他愤怒。他在我们的采访中两次提起这件事，每次都愤愤不平。
And you need to make sure you're getting the proper amount of sleep so that blah, blah, blah. That it's on you. I'm sorry, Admiral. It's not. It's on you. It's on you to set the conditions where that's not-- oh, well, I didn't sleep. And that's a competition-- where you're not creating competition among people. Oh, I slept less than you. Oh, you slept during the middle of the day. You're a dirtbag.
你需要确保获得适当的睡眠，这样诸如此类。这取决于你。抱歉，上将。不是。这取决于你。这取决于你设置条件，让这种情况不是——哦，嗯，我没睡。这是一种竞争——你不是在制造人们之间的竞争。哦，我睡得比你少。哦，你在白天睡觉。你是个混蛋。
But that's the mentality. That's the mentality that drives this [BLEEP]. It's, oh, this is a tough job. And sailors just need to man up. And millennials these days are-- you know, they're soft. It's all garbage. It's always been a bad idea. It's always been bad to not let people get enough sleep.
但这确实是那种心态。那种推动这种[脏话]的心态。这是，哦，这是一份艰苦的工作。水手们只需要像个男人。现在的千禧一代是——你知道，他们很软弱。这全是垃圾。让人们无法获得足够的睡眠一直是个坏主意。
People have told me that a lack of sleep is a problem in all branches of the military. But the Navy is the worst-- the workweeks of 100 hours or more, sleeping just a couple hours for days on end. I spoke to the Navy's lead researcher on sleep deprivation and its effects on sailors, Nita Shattuck, to see exactly how pervasive this was. Did I just find some isolated incidents, or was this everywhere?
人们告诉我，睡眠不足是所有军种中的一个问题。但海军是最糟糕的——每周工作100小时或更多，连续几天只睡几个小时。我采访了海军研究睡眠不足及其对水手影响的首席研究员妮塔·沙图克，看看这种情况到底有多普遍。我只是发现了孤立事件，还是这无处不在？
Dr. Shattuck's gone out with sailors in deployment and equipped them with essentially very expensive Fitbits to see how much sleep they get. She told me that, on average, sailors get a little less than six hours of sleep a night, close to five hours a night when they're on deployment. She said it's a huge problem, maybe bigger than the Navy would like to admit.
沙图克博士在部署中与水手一起外出，并为他们配备了本质上非常昂贵的Fitbits，看看他们睡了多少觉。她告诉我，平均而言，水手每晚睡不到六个小时，部署时每晚接近五个小时。她说这是一个巨大的问题，也许比海军愿意承认的还要大。
The official report on the McCain and Fitzgerald accidents lists a bunch of reasons for the accidents, training and leadership failures, and only devotes two sentences to fatigue. Shattuck thinks it's probably more significant than that.
关于麦凯恩号和菲茨杰拉德号事故的官方报告列出了事故的一堆原因，训练和领导力的失败，只有两句话专门讲疲劳。沙图克认为它可能比那更重要。
You know, I completely acknowledge that-- when I look at things, my husband laughs at me. And he says, you think it's all about sleep. But fatigue could be the major cause of a lot of this that's going on.
你知道，我完全承认——当我看着事物时，我丈夫嘲笑我。他说，你认为这一切都是关于睡眠。但疲劳可能是导致这种情况发生的很多原因的主要原因。
So this report does not convince you otherwise?
所以这份报告并没有让你相信其他情况？
Given the timing, given the circumstances that I'm aware of, I think that fatigue is still a big part of this story.
鉴于时间安排，鉴于我所知道的情况，我认为疲劳仍然是这个故事的很大一部分。
The timing being both accidents happened during the graveyard shift, 1:30 AM and 5:24 AM. I asked the Navy for details about how they knew the crews on the McCain and Fitzgerald were fatigued, how fatigued they were, and whether they could share the crew's schedules from the days before the accidents. They said they could not share that.
时间安排是两起事故都发生在墓地班，凌晨1:30和5:24。我要求海军提供关于他们如何知道麦凯恩号和菲茨杰拉德号上的船员疲劳、他们有多疲劳、以及他们是否能分享事故前几天的船员时间表的细节。他们说他们无法分享那个。
But they did let me speak with Rear Admiral Jesse Wilson. He's the leader of the Atlantic surface fleet. And he said, for instance on the Fitzgerald, it was clear the crew was overworked the day of the accident.
但他们确实让我与海军少将杰西·威尔逊交谈。他是大西洋水面舰队的领导人。他说，例如在菲茨杰拉德号上，很明显船员在事故当天过度劳累。
The ship's routine was very busy that day. And there were indications that certain watch standards were not well-rested, including the commanding officer himself. So more times than not, if one person on the team would have done something differently, would have said something differently, it could have changed the result of the entire event and, in this particular case, could have prevented a collision.
船上的日常工作那天非常忙。有迹象表明某些值班标准没有得到充分休息，包括指挥官本人。所以更多时候，如果团队中的一个人做了不同的事，说了不同的话，它可能会改变整个事件的结果，并在这个特定情况下，可能防止碰撞。
Dr. Shattuck, the Navy sleep researcher, says one of the most problematic issues, and the thing that makes the Navy worse than all of the other branches, is that many sailors are on schedules that make them go to sleep at a different time every day-- which means one day bedtime might be 5:00 PM. The next, it might be 8:00 AM. Our bodies aren't built to do that, so sailors are constantly jet lagged.
海军睡眠研究员沙图克博士说，最棘手的问题之一，也是让海军比其他所有军种更糟糕的事情，是许多水手处于让他们每天在不同时间睡觉的时间表上——这意味着有一天睡觉时间可能是下午5:00。下一次，可能是上午8:00。我们的身体天生不是那样做的，所以水手们总是处于时差反应中。
So why has the Navy allowed it to happen? Well, in part out of necessity. The Navy is understaffed. It's been steadily shrinking for decades. And even though we have about the same operational demands as we have since the '90s, the number of ships available to do that work has decreased by half.
那么为什么海军允许它发生呢？嗯，部分出于必要。海军人员不足。几十年来它一直在稳步萎缩。尽管我们拥有自90年代以来大约相同的行动需求，但可用于完成该工作的船只数量减少了一半。
And on those ships, 14,000 jobs are unfilled, about 10%. The Navy has the money to make those hires. But they're having trouble recruiting people. That means the sailors we do have are much busier. They go out on longer deployments. And they wind up working longer hours.
而在那些船上，14,000个职位空缺，大约10%。海军有钱进行那些招聘。但他们在招人方面有困难。这意味着我们确实拥有的水手忙碌得多。他们进行更长的部署。他们最终工作更长时间。
Earlier this fall, Navy veteran and US senator John McCain expressed his concern about this at an armed services hearing about the collisions. McCain's father and grandfather, by the way, were both Navy admirals and both named John McCain. They're the ones the destroyer USS John McCain is named for. The senator said this to the chief of naval operations, Admiral John Richardson.
今年秋天早些时候，海军老兵和美国参议员约翰·麦凯恩在一次关于碰撞的武装部队听证会上表达了他的担忧。顺便说一句，麦凯恩的父亲和祖父都是海军上将，都叫约翰·麦凯恩。他们就是驱逐舰美国约翰·麦凯恩号的名字来源。这位参议员对海军作战部长约翰·理查森海军上将说了这样的话。
Admiral, is it true that some of our sailors are working 100-hour weeks?
上将，我们的一些水手每周工作100小时是真的吗？
Sir, I'll not deny that. The sailors are working very hard. We have been doing some work study-- sort of workday type of studies.
长官，我不会否认这一点。水手们工作非常努力。我们一直在做一些工作研究——某种工作日类型的研究。
OK. But I'll just point out if we know that somebody's working a 100-hour workweek, I'm not sure we need a study.
好的。但我只是指出如果我们知道某人每周工作100小时，我不确定我们需要研究。
It's worth noting that all of the accidents this year have been in the 7th Fleet, the busiest fleet in the Navy. They're in the Pacific and responsible for patrolling the waters around North Korea, Japan, and the South China Sea, all very tense, very high action areas right now.
值得注意的是，今年所有的事故都发生在第七舰队，海军最繁忙的舰队。他们在太平洋，负责在朝鲜、日本和南中国海周围水域巡逻，所有这些现在都是非常紧张、高行动的区域。
In the wake of the McCain and Fitzgerald deaths, the Navy took steps to fix the problem of fatigue. In October, the Navy announced that it was going to start doing what Dr. Shattuck, the Navy sleep researcher, had been advocating for years. Make it mandatory that sailors sleep at generally the same time every day. The Navy calls it implementing circadian rhythms. All large ships, like destroyers, should have implemented the new schedules this month. Some smaller ships are expected to implement the policy this spring.
在麦凯恩号和菲茨杰拉德号死亡事件发生后，海军采取了步骤来解决疲劳问题。10月，海军宣布它将开始做海军睡眠研究员沙图克博士多年来一直主张的事情。强制水手每天在基本相同的时间睡觉。海军称之为实施昼夜节律。所有大型舰艇，如驱逐舰，应该在本月实施新的时间表。一些较小的船只预计在今年春天实施该政策。
I found a sailor on an assault ship that's been under circadian rhythms his entire deployment. So according to the Navy, he should be getting enough sleep. But he told me that in practice, even though he gets to go to bed at the same time every day, he still works 16 hours each day and has just eight hours off.
我发现了一名在突击舰上的水手，他在整个部署过程中都处于昼夜节律之下。所以根据海军的说法，他应该获得足够的睡眠。但他告诉我，实际上，尽管他每天在同一时间上床睡觉，他仍然每天工作16小时，休息时间只有8小时。
The only way he could possibly get a full eight hours of sleep is if he skipped showering, reading, or relaxing for a single minute and instead collapsed directly on his rack and started sleeping right after duty. But of course, that's impossible. When he lies down, he says, he isn't able to fall asleep immediately and often thinks about work for a couple hours before he can drift off. He told me, quote, "If you're a human being in this system, you are OK with disrespecting your well-being every day."
他唯一可能获得完整的八小时睡眠的方法是，如果他跳过洗澡、阅读或放松整整一分钟，而是直接倒在架子上，在值班后立即开始睡觉。但当然，那是不可能的。他说，当他躺下时，他无法立即入睡，经常在入睡前思考工作几个小时。他告诉我，引用，“如果你是这个系统中的一个人，你每天都接受不尊重自己的福祉。”
Brad Martin believes circadian rhythms are not going to fix the fatigue and accident problems in the 7th Fleet. He's a retired Navy surface warfare captain. He held four commands during his 30 years in the service. Now he's a senior policy researcher at the RAND Corporation.
布拉德·马丁认为昼夜节律不会解决第七舰队的疲劳和事故问题。他是一位退休的海军水面战上校。他在服役的30年里担任过四个指挥官。现在他是兰德公司的高级政策研究员。
That's going to be helpful. But I don't think just fixing that one thing is going to solve the whole problem.
那会有所帮助。但我不认为只解决那一件事情就能解决整个问题。
He doesn't think the Navy can solve the problem without hiring and training people to fill the 14,000 vacancies it has on its ships.
他不认为海军能在不招聘和培训人员填补船上14,000个空缺的情况下解决这个问题。
Ultimately, more people are going to have to be retained or brought in. Putting people through the training pipeline is a tens of millions of dollars type of problem.
最终，必须保留或引入更多的人。让人们通过培训管道是一个数千万美元级别的问题。
Yeah. But then fixing the McCain and the Fitzgerald, those two ships alone is $800 million, so--
是的。但随后修复麦凯恩号和菲茨杰拉德号，那两艘船本身就是8亿美元，所以——
That's a very good point. If we could have spent $70 million to try to get ensured that the manning on those ships was such that we could confidently say they are really ready to go out and operate, it would have been a lot cheaper.
这是一个很好的点。如果我们能花7000万美元来确保那些船上的配备是我们可以自信地说它们真正准备好出去操作的情况，那会便宜得多。
In the Navy, sleep is the canary in the coal mine. Martin told me it's a warning of much deeper, systemic problems. When the Navy puts on a three carrier show of strength off the Korean peninsula, or sends a destroyer to the South China Sea, the whole point is to project an image of American power. But the reality is the Navy is trying to do too much with too little. And behind those dangerous, powerful machines are sailors trying to stay awake at the controls.
在海军中，睡眠是矿井里的金丝雀。马丁告诉我，这是对更深层、系统性问题的警告。当海军在朝鲜半岛外进行三艘航母的力量展示，或派遣一艘驱逐舰到南中国海时，其重点全部是为了投射美国力量的形象。但现实是海军正试图以太少的人做太多的事。在那些危险、强大的机器后面是试图在控制台上保持清醒的水手。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our show.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "AN HONEST MISTAKE" BY THE BRAVERY]
[音乐 - The Bravery的"AN HONEST MISTAKE"]
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis. Our team includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Hilary Elkins, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Michelle Harris, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, B.A. Parker, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
我们今天的节目由达纳·奇维斯制作。我们的团队包括埃尔娜·贝克、伊莉斯·伯格森、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、希拉里·埃尔金斯、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米歇尔·哈里斯、戴维·克斯滕鲍姆、赛斯·林德、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、B.A.帕克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know his Christmas present for me this year? I don't know. It just-- it just seemed a little hostile.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，即公共广播交易所，分发到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道他今年给我的圣诞礼物吗？我不知道。它只是——它看起来有点敌意。
Yes, it is a bomb sitting on a bomb.
是的，它确实是一枚坐在炸弹上的炸弹。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。